right now we're located on radio row in
the Sirius XM area and behind me Kevin
Hart
broadcasting with the plastic cup boys
from his Sirius XM show straight from
the heart
now Kevin join me a little earlier and
he wanted to make sure that I knew that
he has the number one comedy in the
country in theaters right now so quick
don't put your lips on the mic go see
the upside I know it's coffee in the
club Coffee Nebu show is called Kevin
Hardin the plastic cup boys what goes
into plastic cup o coffee what do you
think we are and alcohol drink enough
you know last year's the game you got a
good time yeah I had a great time you
even went down on the field will you be
out of control this year cuz you also
cussed me out if you remember no here's
the thing
I'm um I'm in a suite with a Robert
Graham I'm not of asia's and if they
women you'll see me behind Bobby or in
the field he may be tight with Pat owner
Bobby Kraft but his boys you didn't fly
with him no no he made us all fly
commercial
why he's doing the 16 person jet by
itself why wouldn't you just get on the
plane that's not true the reason why is
I need my space why don't you have
friends I've been wondering this for
quite some time I've never seen you with
friends do you have for him I'm gonna
tell you something these are all my
friends now because I'm gonna take them
to the game
[Music]